KEVIN FIVES: All right.
First of all, thank you
all so much for being here.
My name is Kevin.
And today, Montana
and I are going
to talk to you about
machine learning.
Now, this may not
be the first time
that you've heard
someone from Google talk
about machine learning.
We talk about it a lot.
In fact, our CEO, Sundar,
has gone as far as
to say that we will move
from a mobile first world
to an AI first world.
But when we talk to
developers, the question
that we get most
often is how to think
about machine learning within
the context of their business.
Sure, they've
heard about AlphaGo
or they've used Google Photos.
But what about practical
ways they can start
with machine learning today?
Now, we have a diverse
audience here today.
There's a mix of businesspeople
and product managers, designers
and developers.
Some of you might be
experts in machine learning.
Others maybe have
heard the term.
But you're not quite
sure where to start
or what all the fuss is about.
So we're going break
the talk into two parts.
Mine will be pretty short.
I'm going to give sort of the
high-level, practical overview
of machine learning to make
sure that everyone has context
for Montana's section.
Montana will then
share how Instacart
uses machine learning and
the real-world problems
that they're solving using ML.
So let's get started.
So the first question is, why
using machine learning at all?
And to answer this, I'd like
to give a very simple example.
What if I was to
ask you to write
a program that
tells the difference
between an apple and an orange?
You might start by
writing manual rules.
For example, maybe you'd count
the number of orange pixels
in an image versus the
number of green pixels
and compare the ratio.
And that might work
for these two images.
But the problem with
writing manual rules
is that it doesn't scale.
And for every rule
that you come up with,
I can find an example
that breaks that rule.
For instance, what if I
gave you an image that
was in black and white, or what
if instead of a green apple,
I gave you an image
of a red apple?
Accounting for all
of these exceptions
and writing all of
these rules would
require lots and lots of code.
And if I gave you a similar
problem in the future,
like tell me the difference
between a raspberry
and a strawberry, you'd
need to start all over.
Clearly, there has
to be a better way.
Rather than relying
on manual rules,
machine learning
learns from examples.
And the general way that a
machine learning model works is
you take a set of inputs-- in
this case, labelled images.
You feed them into a
machine learning model--
in this case, a
convolutional neural network.
And the model makes predictions.
And if the predictions are
incorrect, what happens
is it actually slightly
adjusts the model
to make it more accurate.
Generally, the
more data that you
put into a machine learning
model, the more accurate
it will be.
What this allows
you to do is then
you can take a new set of
data that's totally unlabeled,
feed it into a machine
learning model,
and the model will
tell you either
that this is an
orange or an apple.
Now, I'm simplifying
a little bit here.
Montana, please don't kill me.
But, in general, when you think
of the workflow for machine
learning, there are really three
steps that you need to follow.
The first is to collect data.
So what does data mean?
Data comes in different forms.
Data can be images or audio.
It can be numbers in a
database or a spreadsheet.
It can be structured, or
it can be unstructured.
The data collection
step specifically--
by that, I mean quantity of
data, quality of data, maybe
which features you choose
to include in your model--
is often the most
challenging step to getting
started with machine learning.
When we talk to developers,
this is the biggest obstacle
that they have to overcome.
And Montana's going to talk
about this a little bit more
in a minute.
The second step is you
need to choose your model.
Models come in
different flavors, too.
There are deep learning models
and shallow learning models.
There are pre-built
models, or models
that you can build on your own.
There are models that need
labelled data and those that
don't.
This is often a
step that I think
developers that are
new to machine learning
are most intimidated by.
But the truth is for most
common machine learning tasks,
there are open source
models that you can use.
So when you choose a model,
what should you think about?
The first thing is, what
problem are you trying to solve?
There are different ML models
for different problems.
The second is, what data do
you have at your disposal?
And then the third is, what
other considerations do
you have?
For example, are there
latency requirements
where you might need to use
on device machine learning,
or are there compute
restrictions?
The last step is to
predict and tune.
Now, tuning really depends on
your level of sophistication.
If you're new to machine
learning, like I said,
there are plenty of models
you can use that don't
require any tuning at all.
But if you're more
sophisticated,
there are things you
can do to tweak a model
and make it more accurate.
So that's great.
What about real-world use cases?
What problems can machine
learning actually solve?
So I put together
some use cases that I
think are broadly applicable
to folks in this room.
This is not a
comprehensive list.
The beauty of machine
learning really
is that it can solve many, many
different types of problems.
I should also caveat this by
saying that in some cases,
you can solve some of these
problems in multiple ways.
But one framework
that you can use
when thinking
about what problems
you can solve for
your specific business
is to start with what
kind of data's available.
If you have high-quality,
labelled data,
you can do something
called supervised learning.
And supervised learning
kind of has two buckets.
The first is classification--
identify an image.
The second is regression--
for the game
developers in the room,
maybe forecasting
LTV or predicting
the likelihood that a given
transaction is fraudulent.
Even if you don't have
high-quality, labelled data,
you can still conduct what
we call unsupervised learning
tasks.
This is essentially where
the model will infer patterns
or commonalities in data.
And you can use clustering
or association models
to do things like
segment your customers
or determine which product
you want to cross-sell
at the time of purchase.
So I'm not going to spend
too much more time here.
Montana has some
really great examples
that he's going to
share in about a minute.
And it's easy to get started.
Like I said, there are plenty
of pre-trained and off-the-shelf
models you can use using the
Google Cloud Machine Learning
API, things like vision,
speech, translation,
and natural language.
I'd also encourage everyone
to check out TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is the
best-in-class and most popular
open source machine
learning library.
It's the same code
that we use internally
for most of our projects
internally at Google.
Finally, since this
a mobile audience,
I wanted to let
you know that we're
making mobile-specific
investments as well.
So three quick plugs--
the first is that
with MR1, which
is coming later this year, we'll
be announcing the Neural Nets
API, which enables hardware
acceleration on the device.
The second is TensorFlow
Lite, something
that we announced at
Google I/O this year,
we're also hoping to launch
before the end of the year.
TensorFlow Lite is
essentially TensorFlow
that's optimized for
smartphone runtimes.
And then third, we're working
on a set of top-level APIs
that make common machine
learning tasks easier.
I'd also like to say if anyone
is thinking about machine
learning at all, we
have Brahim, who's
our PM for machine
learning at Android,
as well as a number
of our engineers
that are going to be
in the classroom later.
Please, please go find them.
They'd love to hear
about what problems
you're trying to
solve and answer
any questions that you have.
So with that, I'd like
to introduce Montana,
who's going to talk
about how Instacart
uses machine learning.
[APPLAUSE]
MONTANA LOW: Thanks, Kevin.
So I'm always
impressed when somebody
can summarize a very complex
topic in three easy steps.
My artistic friend did one
better when I asked them,
how do you draw an owl?
Well, they said,
first, you start off
with a circle and
another circle.
And this is sort of
the head and the body.
And then you just
draw the damn owl.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I'm going to try and break
this down, those three steps,
into quite a few more as we
go through several high-level
overviews of when we
use supervised learning
in Instacart, when we use
unsupervised learning.
And at the end of
the talk, we'll
go through a detailed
feature development use case.
And we'll talk about how
we start and how we finish.
To begin, I'd like to give you
some context of what Instacart
is, how our business works,
so that you understand
why we would use
machine learning
to solve any problem we have.
We deliver groceries from
the stores you love in
as little as an hour.
We connect personal
shoppers to our customers
so that they can deliver the
service those customers expect
in real time.
We also partner with
hundreds of retailers
around the country so that we
can shop out of their stores.
We can provide discount prices.
That way, we have
deep integrations
with their product catalogs
we host on our website.
And the fourth party
in this marketplace
are the actual
product manufacturers.
We partner with them to give our
customers discounts, coupons,
and other incentives
on the website.
So at the heart of this is a ton
of data passing back and forth
between a lot of parties.
And what really
drives this engine
in terms of growth
and efficiency
are deep machine
learning models.
I'm going to walk you through
the customer experience
to begin.
When they get to the
app, they choose a store.
They shop for their groceries.
They go ahead and
check out in the app.
We have all their payment
information saved.
So it's real easy.
They select a delivery time
that's convenient for them.
And after that, we've
got it in the bag.
I promise that's the
only pun in this talk--
[LAUGHTER]
--I think.
On the other side of the
transaction, there's a shopper.
The shopper lets us know when
they're available to do work.
They'll acknowledge an
order as it comes in.
They'll go pick all of the
groceries for that customer.
We make sure that they scan
every item for accuracy.
This is actually a step
that improves their speed
because it's easier for your
phone to tell you yes or no
when you're trying to
decide 2%, 1%, light, whole.
All the labels look the same.
So this is a nice improvement.
And then the shopper
actually delivers it
to the customer's address.
We don't discriminate
between cats and dogs.
We're an equal pet service.
But I'd like to show you an
example of one of our teams
that uses machine learning
pretty extensively.
It's our search
and discovery team,
which powers our storefront
that all of our customers use.
If you think about search when
you're dealing with a product
catalog, very minor
changes in search terms
should have a completely
different results page.
What you see on a
milk results page
should be completely different
than a chocolate milk results
page and should be complete
different than a milk chocolate
results page.
That's hard if you're
just using text.
So one reason we
use machine learning
is to extract more meaning and
provide more relevant results.
The beginning of any
machine learning problem
is to break down all of your
input into specific features,
in this case, the features
of all of our product.
Is it USDA?
Is it organic?
What's the fat content?
What's the size
of the container?
What's the color of the image?
All of these become
features of products.
And so we don't really think
of products as an ID or a name.
But they're a huge collection
of potentially dozens
or more of these features.
And the important thing
about all of these features
is that they can be
quantified numerically.
For color, we can assign
red, green, blue numbers.
Machine learning models
only work with numbers.
Fundamentally, they're
arithmetic all the way down.
So if we can quantify milk
in a series of features,
they're embedded as
numbers in our models.
Then we can actually apply
really advanced mathematics
to get better search results.
So the way that we actually
translate a search ranking
problem into a supervised
machine learning problem
is we use the signal of
when a user adds a search
result to their cart.
If they actually decide to buy
something that we show them
when they search for
milk, that's a supervisor
saying, this is the
correct search result.
There's also an
implicit negative signal
there of everything else
we show them on the page
isn't quite as milky to them.
So doing this with
libraries like TensorFlow
that Kevin pointed out, we can
really improve the situation.
And what's even cooler is that
as we launch new retailers
and add hundreds of new
products to our catalog
every single day,
we can identify
what new products
will also be highly
ranked search results
immediately because we look
at these products in
terms of their features,
not in terms of any
individual products history.
So the fact that this
product has similar features
to other things that have
ranked highly for milk
means this product should
probably rank highly for milk
as well.
Once you've built one
machine learning model
and you've got your
data in a good shape,
then you can start to think
about all of the other signals
you have.
One of the super
powers of deep learning
is called transfer learning.
You can take the understanding
that one model has developed--
in this case, our
search results model.
It understands that these
particular features are closely
related to the term
"milk," or in this case,
these two sets of
features, the ones that
represent Coca-Cola and
Pepsi, are closely related
to the term "cola."
In terms of their features,
they're very similar.
We could subtract them and
get 0 in mathematical sense.
But what we see when we
have Coca-Cola and Pepsi
is that people
almost never add them
to the cart at the same time.
So this is another signal that
even though these two products
have incredibly
similar features,
they're never added to
the cart at the same time,
making them competitive.
So now we can
start merchandising
all of our website.
And when people are
looking at Coke,
they should also see
Pepsi when people
are looking at all of these
different types of items
that are similar.
We can take another signal, very
similar, but it's the opposite.
In this case, peanut
butter and jelly
are often added to the
cart at the same time.
But they have very
dissimilar features.
So using this
knowledge we have now
about what features are
similar and how they work,
we can recommend products.
After we see you add
peanut butter to your cart,
then we can, say,
hey you probably
are forgetting the jelly.
And that's a
different application
than organizing our
storefront in the beginning.
All of this requires that we
collect the data from the user,
acting as a supervisor
for our machine
learning algorithms that are
continuously running and taking
in new data over time.
I'd like to move
on to an example
of unsupervised learning
that Kevin mentioned.
It's called clustering.
In this case, we
don't necessarily
start with the answers.
We don't have somebody
training our algorithm
with the correct answer.
We start with questions.
We want to know more about who
our users are, what they want,
what motivates them.
Some people in the past
would use demographic data
to understand their user base.
But that's sort of
irrelevant in many cases.
It doesn't really matter how
old you are or what sex you are
or what age you are
when you're talking
about behavior-driven
development.
What we want to do is we want to
actually segment our users not
by these superficial
qualities, but instead
by how they actually use the
app and derive value from it.
It starts just the same way.
We break our users down
into a set of features.
It might be what platform are
they visiting the site on,
what time of day do
they come to the site.
A funny one is aol.com
email addresses
are significantly different
than gmail.com email addresses.
Those users tend to
engage with the site
differently at different
times of the day.
And so even at sign-up time,
we know a lot about a user
and how they're going to behave.
We can use an unsupervised
learning model
to begin to cluster these users.
And so it will actually
begin to pull out
groups of these people.
In this case, I've
asked for three groups
from the-- and that's the
only parameter I specify
for the model because I want
to maybe make a small, medium,
and a large version
of my product.
And I want to decide
what should those three
versions of my product be.
In this case, we've
got group one, which
are green people, group two,
which are orange people,
and group three,
which are blue people.
To begin with, the
unsupervised model
has just told me
that blue people
are very much like blue people.
Orange people are very
much like orange people.
And green people are very
much like green people.
But that doesn't really
help me too much.
What I need to then do
is do some deep analysis
on the green people
versus the orange people
versus the blue people versus
our normal overall global user
base.
And what I might find
is that green people
tend for organic food.
Orange people tend
to prefer spicy food.
And blue people really love
ice cream late at night
with a frozen pizza.
So that's one way that we
can use machine learning
to plan how we're
going to build products
that people are going to engage
with, even before we launch.
I'd like to go through
a detailed analysis
on what our product
development looks like.
This is a case for
picking groceries.
We do a lot of
It's where a huge
portion of time goes.
We have this enormous catalog
that shoppers are handed
in a single shopping list.
They go out to all
these different stores
that they may never
have been to before.
And eventually, they
will complete the order.
If we can save 10 seconds, 20
seconds per order, at scale,
this becomes hugely
valuable to the company.
So we've looked at lots of
ways to improve their speed.
I've mentioned the
bar code scanner
was one incidental metric.
But when we do these
things at scale,
it becomes very
difficult. We have
hundreds of different
retailers that we partner with,
millions of products,
thousands of stores.
Actually organizing the data on
how every single store is laid
out is incredibly challenging.
So we go to our CEO after
he says, speed up picking.
I said, well, if
we could just be
like some of our
competitors, why don't we
just build their warehouses?
And then we'll know
where everything is.
And we can have robots do this.
And it'll be super fast.
Apoorva said no.
That's not our business model.
We don't build warehouses.
We shop out of
stores people like.
So we said, OK.
Well, maybe we can get more data
about each individual store.
And maybe we can sort the
shopping lists that way.
And we can speed
up shopping time.
So we do a little weekend
hackathon project.
And it's a little
Rails app that lets
us take where baby accessories
are and put them on an aisle
number in the store.
And then some shift
lead in a store
can drag and drop
all of our categories
in order, like they say
aisle 15 comes after aisle 14
after aisle 13.
And then when we ship a
shopping list this way,
we can put things in
the order that has
been specified at that store.
This is our baseline
control, where we started.
If you notice, it goes
up into the right,
which is generally good.
In this case, what
that means is as we
add more items to the order,
the individual time per item
goes down.
So it's an improvement--
that if you're
shopping for 10
items in the store,
you have to walk
around the whole store
to only get 10 items.
If you're shopping for
50 items in a store,
you walk around the whole
store still only one time.
But now you've got 50 items.
So we've known for a
long time that this
is a key to our business.
What we haven't
known is if we can
change the shape of this curve.
When we launched
that experiment,
we actually showed that
there's a significant slope
improvement.
We're very excited.
Unfortunately, this
is too expensive.
Our CEO says this
works in one store.
That's great.
But next week, when they
move everything around again,
we're going to have to
go do this over again.
And by the way, we're
growing insanely fast.
So I can't see us sparing
the labor hours to do this.
So we say, OK, fine, Apoorva.
Maybe there's something
smarter we can do.
We have phones with GPS on them.
Shoppers are in these
stores eight hours a day.
They're picking
hundreds of times a day.
Maybe we can actually sort
of map implicitly using GPS.
We know the time they pick
the item because they're
scanning the bar code.
We know relatively where they
are in this store with GPS.
If we see enough picks on
that product, over time,
we can start to map
the whole store.
And we can start to build up
a detailed analysis of where
the baby diapers
are in this store.
Once we have a map like
this, for any given order,
we can plot the dots on the map.
We can solve the traveling
salesman problem.
We can actually solve
it for small orders.
We use heuristic approximations
for large orders.
And the results for that were
exciting, but disappointing
because we actually saw
significant improvement
over baseline.
And now we're not paying
anybody to do this.
Now this is implicit data
that we get for free.
It's just an algorithm running.
But we know that it's not
really as good as what
the humans were able to do.
There's some deficiencies
in this algorithm
that-- it doesn't
know where walls are.
So it might ask you to
walk through an aisle.
And so we weren't quite
ready to stop there.
We started looking
around for, is there
tech that will give us more
accurate mapping information?
We're really
excited about things
like Google Tango coming out.
A lot of this AR is
going to be big for us.
It's going to really change
the way we do things.
But it's not really
ubiquitous yet.
So we can't expect
all of our shoppers
to go buy brand new
devices to shop with us.
Once we've exhausted all of
the options, what do we do?
We smear some machine
learning on the problem
and see what happens.
So in any machine
learning problem,
you need a formal
problem statement.
We like to do our problem
statements in emoji.
In this case, you
have 10 products
of some corn to coffee.
And the goal of this
machine learning algorithm
is to put those products
in the correct sequence
so that then we can
predict the sequence.
For a specific instance
stated mathematically,
the probability
that the next item
is going to be the cookie given
that the last item is bread,
and your candidates
are the items that
remain to be shopped,
is the function
that we're trying to learn with
the machine learning model.
We use a TensorFlow
architecture to build
this machine learning model.
In this case, you can see
that our model actually
takes features from
several different things.
It considers what the features
of the shopper that's shopping
is, how experienced are
they, how long have they been
on shift, how many refunds they
typically do during an order,
how quickly do they
typically shop an order.
It looks at the
warehouse location
that they're at
so that it can say
how big is this place, how
confusingly is it laid out,
do they typically have
things that are out of stock
that they haven't told us about.
It looks at the previous
item that they just picked,
which in this case is bread.
And it looks at the next
item that they might pick.
One really important thing
that I touched on earlier
is this notion of embeddings.
When you have
features for a product
that are numerically
represented, the model--
as it's incrementally updated,
it embeds that set of features
into itself.
And so, in this
case, we actually
have two products
that are coming
into this model as features.
TensorFlow lets us
share that embedding.
So the model only has to learn
about products one time, which
doubles the efficiency.
The goal of this model
is to actually make
a prediction of whether
the chocolate bar will
be the next item picked
given that bread was
the previous item picked
there at this retailer
with this shopper.
With enough examples, we can
actually train this model
and learn this function.
We're going to call this thing,
this model that we've just
trained, the score generator.
And we're going to set it
up-- the top right-hand corner
for now--
and go a little
bit deeper in how
we use this score generator
to actually sequence an order.
We generate a score
for every product
given the input features.
And then we do that for
every remaining product
inside the availability set.
You can see that
it's going to predict
several different scores.
Some things are very
probable to be picked next.
Some things are less
We take the most
likely one of that.
Softmax is a fancy
mathematical term for that.
We get a prediction.
And we actually
use cross-entropy,
which is a way to teach the
model that these answers are
constrained to the available
ones you're looking at now.
There are millions of other
products in our catalog.
I don't know if you're
familiar with "Silicon Valley,"
if anybody watches that.
The hot dog/no hot dog
machine learning classifier--
he couldn't actually
make it universal.
He couldn't train it
so that it can actually
do more than one thing.
Our classifier actually
can consider all things
because it's a single
model that represents
all stores, all
products, confined
to the very small list of
available products remaining
in your shopping list.
That's the
cross-entropy function--
gives us that
little extra nudge.
And so given that model, we can
now actually make predictions
every step of the way that corn
will be the most likely item
picked first.
Given that they've
just picked corn,
what will be the next
item that they pick?
With all the rest
of these, we repeat
that until we've actually
exhausted the entire list
of available products.
And then we can show
that to the shoppers.
So the question is, this
sounds really complicated,
does it actually work?
And the answer is smashingly.
We're very, very excited
with the results here.
To give you an idea, if there
are 125 million households
in the US, if 5% of them
do business on Instacart,
they typically shop for
groceries about once a week.
If we can save about
a minute a week,
then that's 618 years of labor
that we save every single week
with a model like this.
Once we have a model in
production like this,
it's really easy to tweak
it to add more features
to see which ones
make sense, which ones
are harming the
model's performance,
to add extra hidden layers.
We went through about seven
iterations on this one.
And we actually doubled
the performance of it
compared to the baseline.
So we're at over a millennia
saved per week now,
which we're very happy about.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's all I've got.
I'm going to turn it
back over to Kevin,
who should be able to
give us some closing
notes before lunch.